so i better hush for you christ after
death and we can't finish the show
like a lot of americans i'm under a lot
of stress right now
dolly parton appeared on tuesday's
episode of the late show
and had stephen colbert all up in his
feelings
well thank you so it all started when
the music icon was telling steven about
the songs that her late mom
avi lee owens used to sing to her then
dolly did what dolly does she's saying
delivering a sweet little impromptu
performance of bury me beneath the
willow
bury me beneath the willow
under the weeping willow tree
where he may know where i
am sleeping and perhaps he'll weep for
me
yeah that's when things took a turn for
water work city
population stephen oh it's like so
amazing the 56 year old late night host
who lost his mom lorna in 2013
even mined to someone off camera that he
was getting goosebumps
are you crying oh bury me
beneath the willow
under the weeping willow tree
where he may know where i
am sleeping and perhaps he'll
eat for me so i better hush for you
christ after death and we can't finish
the show
like a lot of americans i'm under a lot
of stress right now
dolly really you and
under my tripwire right there i'll tell
you right there that was pretty
beautiful
and you know what dolly she's just like
us
okay well she cries just like us
we used to cry when my boys sing them i
would cried we'd cry
those little songs were just amazing
though isn't it funny that sometimes
there's nothing happier than a cry
isn't that isn't that yeah i think
that's the cleanse is your soul
i think water is good to wash it out yup
twitter four i think
in fact earlier in their chat dolly
opened up about turning to music for her
own therapy to help others
i just feel like i can express myself
in ways that i don't need a doctor for i
don't have to have therapy i can just
kind of
sing it all out write it all out and i
can write for other people too like you
said because
i see things happen to other people and
i think they don't know how to express
how they feel
so they're depressed or they're sad so i
write songs for them as well
and you know what steven isn't the only
celeb dolly has brought to tears
yeah this sort of thing seems to happen
regularly
she was a little nervous i could tell
but we we tried
but i sang through it and then got my
voice i had i
literally had barely i couldn't even
have a squeak come out
back in 2018 it caught up with dolly and
jennifer aniston to talk about their
flick
dumplin and jen revealed how she got
emotional
after recording a song with the music
legend when we finished i remember i
just burst into tears
she could did get emotional after she
was done
it was terrifying and fun and all of it
yeah it was great fearless yes
or fearful depending on how you look at
it but i had
you know dolly and linda perry there to
who were just
patient and wonderful
you